yeah hey welcome to podcast ville
[ __ ] the church is brought to you
by me undies me and these makes you feel
good undies your butt will be proud to
wear me undies the best underwear you
could get why cuz they're soft they're
made with mode all and when you're
sweating the stuff they keep everything
nice and cool what I'm gonna do is this
I'm gonna get you 20% off the best and
softest underwear socks you will ever
own with free shipping and a hundred
percent money-back guarantee that's me
undies coms last Joey me undies dot-com
slash Joey listen the holidays are
coming you want to look good you want to
go to Grandma's with nice clean
underwear on go to me undies calm right
now / Joey and get 20% off this podcast
is also brought to you by you ready for
this one the best blue apron choose from
a variety of new recipes each week all
that blue aprons culinary team surprise
you recipes are not repeated within a
year blue apron is the number one fresh
ingredient and recipe delivery service
in the country period via follow me
period why because cooking together
build strong family bonds research shows
that blue apron families cook nearly
three times often this much menus listen
to this a seated chicken a beautiful
shrimp pesto fettuccine and black bean
and cheese tortoise offer you want to
eat those this is how you do it check
out the menu go to me undo our blue
apron go to blue apron comm slash Joey
I'm gonna get your $30 off your first
meal with free shipping by going to blue
apron comm slash Joey you're gonna feel
good cuz it tastes good it's delicious
and the best thing is you get to cook in
front of your family like a chef of the
future go to blue apron calm right now
take that mealy
I'm taking your deep in the murky waters
with Sabbath cause it's that time of the
week when it comes to Sabbath there's
one of my favorite [ __ ] songs of all
time all for the sabotage out the second
hour my fault from Black Sabbath on the
walk home bar burn the line Avenue kick
this muley we got time to [ __ ] around
feel
you
any meal what that's the way to kick off
a [ __ ] Monday morning [ __ ] who the
[ __ ] is gonna stop you
welcome to the Church of what's
happening mom my little brother Theo von
and my [ __ ] favorite Christ killer of
all time
Lisa ad on the [ __ ] drums I hope you
had a great [ __ ] weekend it's fourth
down two yards you're ready to [ __ ]
score no more [ __ ] around the rest of
the year
Theo von I had a blow [ __ ] smoke
cloud I'll respect ah you're so bright I
appreciate that man you made the move
you're [ __ ] a new man you look good
I'm in Del Rio's on fire my dick is
fresh about killing these [ __ ] people
and you still got no broad on the side
you don't want no Brun you're on a
[ __ ] mission from Lucifer mm-hmm not
my guy friend over here he don't give a
[ __ ] he's got a girlfriend he wants to
sigh ass he's ready to go in the dungeon
oh he's too much from owning a George
Foreman gorilla he's all bad these are
nine boxy with the bug festival this
weekend did your aliens never ends it's
not festivals it's a fundraiser I rescue
but get any autograph so I put the table
they put out a wink hasta la a Halloween
costume oh yeah try it's like being a
straight gay guy but it's my little
brother I got accepted what am I gonna
do um thank you I appreciate it he's a
beautiful and one of my 70 favorite
people right there Lisa at the top 70
people in People magazine they had a
favorite Lisa it's a bad [ __ ] my
favorite 70 people dead or alive dude I
don't think I know 70 people yeah you do
every [ __ ] body who dies they always
make 250 bass cards for you did you know
that there really yeah because everybody
on the average knows 250 [ __ ] people
that's why in business you have to be
nice to everybody
Wow everybody knows 250 people hmm
at least not Twitter not face right even
you've been in contact with 250 people
if you die by the age of 50 between
classmates high school mates college
mates people at your job over 25 30
[ __ ] years that's the average well
people don't know that you learned that
when you buy telemarketing the 70s that
will help me in more ways than one
if you want to sell you got that's what
you [ __ ] so yeah it's all in
generations so I'd say you sell [ __ ]
vacuums in you're serious about what you
hope is that Leah becomes your Goomba
and Lee's son buys your vacuums Lee's
daughter buys your vacuums Lee's wife
you know as well you want fifth
generation on the Kim yeah what you do
that's where the good [ __ ] salesman
does yeah so we're you at the
christening you doing everything you
know that yeah good I'll tell you this
my sister used to be a exotic dancer
right she used to be in the [ __ ] with
Louisiana kind of certain areas get out
off living yeah it's tough area
especially out there and now she
actually learned to dance and I remember
this is wild but she learned to dance
and uh like it was like a trailer right
like oh she was like oh you know exotic
place it was a trailer but the stage
wasn't very high and the stage was too
high in the trailer so this dancers had
to crouch and strip at the end dance at
the same time so if you were over like
five four you had to like duck and look
sexy and that's hard to do men think
about that I've never had to think about
that because I'd be fine in that trail
yeah you owe you PETA [ __ ] you beat a
desert dance her bra it bring you out
with the plug-in with the creme brulee
man he would take the stage like a
[ __ ] Thanksgiving treat how many how
many creme brulees do you think we would
dance self
oh that [ __ ] came on every hour
on the hour at least eight at least
eight I would sell eight every 15
minutes like there's only so many people
in the building there's a very small
club let me ask you come to this club to
see me they like desert she's probably
out there for I guess about eight years
eight years in the trailer
oh no she just started there she was
then she went in about buildings that
were zoned correctly and everything
with all you can stretch out you know
did you get mad at all those years were
you set what up let me think man we
weren't really close growing up I mean
always I actually get eleven you were
younger than younger than me
okay yes are you upset I mean I was uh
well the crazy part was honestly we look
alike so I would see dudes sometimes
looking at me like weirdly like around
and when I was out at lunch and [ __ ] you
know and they were like do I know you
[Laughter]
but uh but so I guess that if we
wouldn't have looked alike him on him it
might have not been so wild to me but
you know what dude she didn't have you
know she was missing some elements
growing up and you know I respect that I
respect any women if they out there in
those type of environments cuz it's a
hard environment and that you know
because otherwise if you're not doing
that what what are you doing then you
know if you rat that in but if you're at
that doorstep where you are you know
where you're looking for an occupation
but you're if you're not doing that you
probably up to some dark art you know
[Music]
it's like I don't [ __ ] know what did
you go to that strip club in in the
trailer I mean I been I mean I've been
over there before but I didn't you know
I wouldn't go there with my sister well
no I would hope not but I can't even
admit like is it just like a
construction trailer that they just
poured a little stage in and a couple
folding chairs I mean I don't think that
they had you know a long I don't know if
their what their long-term business
model was you know I mean I'll say that
but they you know it was good it was a
small-town place you know and people
were enjoying themselves and uh but yeah
I mean oh I mean I love my sister she's
the best you know I mean I would I mean
she's a [ __ ] g-man she's a [ __ ] G
you know she's
as real as they get it's crazy because
well what are we talking about what were
we talking about squat in the trailer
but even got into this conversation no
no it's just weird that did she ever go
to a big city and dance would she keep
some ice repour I mean I think she you
know nothing real crazy I don't think I
mean weren't that close a lot of us
married no no no single so single
regular angle ready to mingle cool chick
though kids no kids she kept it together
man yeah that's on saying that's hot
listen you 22 right you're 22 you got
nothing going on I mean what are you
[ __ ] options you're gonna go work at
a vet yeah or a daycare for 8,000 now or
whatever I say young girl I mean you
know and I have a daughter how would it
feel if she came to me and silicone I go
to [ __ ] college but I got an answer
I'm gonna go strip for five years for
four years the four years I could have
been in college I'm gonna go strip but
you're not that intelligent to grasp but
at that time right girls that go into
that go into that I'm not talking about
blind him because they were missing
something
yeah for the first time somebody paid
attention to him yeah so oh yes she was
abuse she had like this and this violent
kind of black boyfriend she dated and
that abused and I think that's what got
her into it you know just uh you don't
give a [ __ ] about yourself but think
about it what with you with what you
know now yeah the knowledge you have now
if you a [ __ ] 19 year old check your
tits were hot you got a nice little ass
all these guys are torturing you all the
time they're [ __ ] broke you know I
mean as a woman you know you know what I
wasn't raised to do this yeah but it's
2,000 [ __ ] 17 yeah I'm gonna go to
Subway and be surrounded by stiffs or
some second who's jerking off of there
anyway so we caught two dudes jerking
off by the our subway and released yeah
there was something about it I think it
was just I don't know could have been
the air freshener something he literally
the subway [ __ ] made you feel erect
but I think they had one of those
lavender air things you know but I'm not
making fun of subway employees
I always not only that the [ __ ] my
biggest fear is when you walk into
subway like oh I thought I was gonna
turn out to be
unless to God and I didn't want this
you're going to subway and everybody's
22 but that's one guy that's 50 with a
ponytail it was you and he's got an
earring and he's still be still cool
mm-hmm like he's still fighting the
[ __ ] cool yeah I'm matter that he
lives in the apartment where they dudes
and what have you got home the other
night they will listen that belong and
doesn't matter what matters is that he
went to see Guns & Roses you know two
weeks ago right this is what's going on
and he's living his life yeah he's
living his life but he didn't really
look at the other part of your life he
didn't look at it ladder when life moves
[ __ ] fast and you're still talking
about some [ __ ] band yeah well
everybody else your age he's growing out
it's growing the [ __ ] up you know it's
kind of a weird I was always scared to
be that guy then that's your five mainly
well I mean don't you think it would
take like a very specific kind of person
to be a be like be a stripper not get
affected by it cuz you're talking like
oh it'd be great who are the [ __ ] ten
right there I sentences two out of ten
if you and make an educated guess yeah I
went to a strip club
a year ago nine months ago I get bored
I'm like any other [ __ ] guy yeah I'm
home one night it's 10:15 everybody's
[ __ ] sleeping yeah everybody's asleep
in my house at 10:15 my couch yeah I
can't even [ __ ] punch somebody yeah I
tried to wake my wife up to give me the
ten depends the iTunes so I could on the
[ __ ] phone she don't even [ __ ] myself
you know I'm sayin everybody's out in my
[ __ ] house at [ __ ] 10:15 yeah so I
go let me go - yum yum donuts - then
you're a fat [ __ ] you just said that
don't stay away for the way yourself yes
and [ __ ] it I got a lot of homo
transvestites if you stay on Colfax and
go up to like victory and make a left is
a strip club and I went in there and I
made an observation you know you just
sitting there looking at [ __ ] intense
and it's phenomenal I'm not gonna say
that yeah I didn't like it or it was
dirty
yeah first of all the strip club is
always empty yeah I mean you can't
believe how empty it is like bone-dry
like this the four [ __ ] guys sitting
there drinking water because it's dude
yeah water
I guess showing they're showing photos
of people that were in there earlier in
the day yes how I can't there's four
people in
and I you know you talk to different
girls there was one girl I talked to her
her boyfriend comes to comedy shows she
comes with him all the time
oh wow and there was another girl that
her boyfriend was the [ __ ] handle the
podcast and and you know you you have
all these girls that are in there that
talk talk to you yeah I looked at them
and I'm like look at that girl she's 18
there was one girl I was 20 you know I
give him the whole bank account oh yeah
you know you look at her and go you eat
you give her the whole bank account
listen just come home and we go get your
clothes
let's go my wife I was yeah i'm sure and
for some dudes that would do that you
have the girl for the 42 left yeah
they're out there bang on it they're
eating grapefruit juice and jumping and
yeah [ __ ] now you know and you gotta
give him a heart like you sit there and
go I know what she's going through
yeah I don't want to pick the 20 year
old because she's gonna feel bad and if
I pick the 20 year old right a 20 year
old Oh glob all over you and suck your
sperm she doesn't know it his HIV out
there and chlamydia of the mouth and
[ __ ] yes he's something is he could you
know where the 40 year old gives you
hand wipes because she knows you're
gonna finger her and she don't want the
leftover salt from the pretzel yet two
hours early it's just really weird bro
when you deal with when they become a
professional yeah like if you ever
bumped into a professional stripper yeah
what's the answer different game was a
single friend game brother it's like
staying at comedy for a certain period
of time it's like there's an everyday
day when you're like you realize oh oh I
know what you're doing all right now I'm
in number there and when you deal with a
professional stripper you go in there
dog
education to the first room first she'll
give you a couple website monkey yeah
man watching Todd chick there she'll
take you upstairs banging out for the
small four bills and that's what she
becomes a London yeah and you're like
what the [ __ ] happens she sold you yeah
shameless stripper no more she's a
saleswoman now yeah you want a [ __ ]
suck that's 2004 this [ __ ] piece ass
yeah you want to look at me mm
[ __ ]
mm they look at you when they gonna
squeeze you know what wanna smell my
[ __ ] need a yogurt at the same time
11 guys normal three thousand five
they're gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] six guys four
yeah and make 12 thousand a week was
$8,000
okay so I've even thought I've thought
about it that if you pay whatever that
is two thousand five hundred that's not
the whole night that's like one one
round I guess you could negotiate
whatever the [ __ ] you want okay thank
God dude what about [ __ ] just
somebody regular and in tipping him
after is that crazy you think like if
it's just a girl you met they get
insulted yeah I could see you telling
the girl listen then I'm gonna go out of
town on Thursday I didn't know this was
gonna happen and a great time you get to
allows them leave it there for you feet
for you doing your toes yeah they also
get yourself watching your girlfriend
you know yeah that's the way to do it
it's how you [ __ ] do it
you know it's not making them feel like
a [ __ ] hooker yeah but but you can't
[ __ ] yeah you know it's like right now
Harvey Weinstein's get in trouble for
this [ __ ] and then yeah he's a pig but
you gotta admit there's a there's a
thousand guys out I used to date a girl
bro that was a stripper mm-hmm and after
a year or two I accepted what she did
and I used to just talk to her sometimes
and by talking to her it really showed
me how pathetic men walk because not
even in my deepest darkest moment would
I do something like that yeah you know
yeah I like [ __ ] again you dick
sucked everybody does everybody likes to
bump into somebody love alien monkey
yeah at the time [ __ ] let's get on
somebody's car see especially the
comedian but to walk into a strip club
right out and this is what they do every
week this is their free this is and I
tell people all the time that you're
married so you have these boundaries
yeah and then you present yourself with
personal boundaries and you go you know
what I got a wife I got a kid I got a
daughter I gotta go home now four [ __ ]
hours my wife don't bang me like she
used to she don't like becoming a handle
more all those days a done yeah and even
with women well women go to a gym maybe
your wife would go to a gym left to [ __ ]
somebody but just to somebody tells you
it was good yeah everybody has their own
needs man yeah
yeah I mean I respect look man I mean
and also you see look Joe you see these
billboards now you see the sugar model
billboard you see this [ __ ] all over
your sugar models right and it's like
escort
basically it's like high-end escorts out
here in LA you can get you know well
it's like it's but it's not set up like
escorts it's like Oh $400 you go to
dinner with this girl for $200 you guys
go to dinner and everything else is kind
of whatever you do is your business
right but it's kind of known that you
know sex is an option you know it's on
the table for you know both sides of the
party so part of me sometimes I'm like
well is it and I don't even think but I
don't think prostitution is a bad
business you know I don't think that it
should be I don't know if I feel like it
should be illegal or not you know but I
think it's weird that women aren't
protests and having these billboards up
because I feel like that in dangers a
lot of women you know it guys but
imitates them I don't know how have you
been here ten years yeah ten years in
your 10 years have you ever and I'm not
saying it correctly a lot of people
gonna get mad at me in your 10 years
have you met a captive woman if you know
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah a kept woman is
yes Lisa aunt makes two million dollars
a year he loves Paula he's been with
Paula he doesn't want to [ __ ] and do
nothing wrong but diandra but what he
does is he got a partner across the
street got an apartment right across the
street right here Lisa I don't pay her
1,200 on a month rent put three of his
fingers in her ass put 500 on a car
payment from our [ __ ] lease Audi
through your company yeah cuz your wife
don't look at your books and you give it
1,500 a month to live that's that's
sweet that 3,500 I am but that's I'm
40,000 but you're making 30 million a
year Lea yeah that's so Lea harmony and
we've had this discussion and you know
it because you live in LA like when I
went to acting class that's when I
started meeting those girls yeah like I
went through a girl's house that was
[ __ ] neighbors wood Shack yeah
like you went through the penthouse the
elevator opened shags door was there and
her door was there yeah there's
something a lot more than 1,200 a month
well yeah because her [ __ ] was worth
you know that's a girl then you come
over she bade you she had your toenails
she rubs cream all over you and then she
goes to [ __ ] town yeah you come home
on you leave there on Saturday morning
like a king again cuz your wife forgot
how to treat you and people around you
figure
teacher so you don't mind going you
extra bug you ever seen episode episode
Markos when they talk about Barry seal
the pilot and when they found him at a
hooker house and then Oh Barry see it
was from the south oh yeah from Baton
Rouge Tom Cruise is playing him in that
movie yes okay they go Barry seal was
from the south he loved [ __ ]
college football and hallucinations
hallucinogenic mind-altering drugs yeah
that made him a perfect CIA agent and
they show him in bed with five [ __ ]
tents five that's a 50 brother what does
that cost you late with that question of
going to walk house and go I want the
five baddest [ __ ] I don't want them
to be dented I don't want them to have
kids
no Molesey oh boy I got a guy like the
Hutton molzof these would be five
playmates yeah the whole night the suck
and [ __ ] toe blood comes out of their
nose that's ten G's a pop you gotta go
and then drop 50 and go I want the more
yeah what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do when we had Dennis HOF on he
told us what they got spent six million
or something crazy yeah between
Thanksgiving Christmas New Year's yeah
Jesus so there's a bunch of kept women
at Hollywood not tell you why they come
out here bro they end up in a roommate
situation up in the [ __ ] valley they
kind of think they did a month after
they get here that car blows up yeah
they're taking buses all around but they
really like Holly wouldn't they stalking
me
and when did he go into a [ __ ] acting
class and they meet some 40 year old
yeah just once again tackling me no only
in fact he knows exactly what he's doing
he's looking for [ __ ] little Guppies
mm-hmm I ain't doing well I'm struggling
I'm a waitress three days a week and I
host this six nights a week and I really
have no time to audition let me think
Hannah yeah you got a boyfriend yeah but
he's an [ __ ] only he doesn't call me
listen you know you're [ __ ] and
sucking don't disrespect me but what if
I come over once a week I get your new
[ __ ] apartment Bella Hill brand new
[ __ ] some new shoes and just had
shoes from talking whatever listen man
how many women will go what what's what
you know Harvey vote for all the women
that turn Harvey Weinstein down and a
[ __ ] saying all this [ __ ] about him
there had to be 50 of them that he
stopped up oh and I bet there were very
hundred of them three men also offered
to him and that he's probably said now
it's crazy this works both ways
specially a town like this where you
have high rents people struggle here the
young actors they have a dream listen
you can still have a dream
yeah yeah I said go to the freakin uh
parlor I see their parlor comedy show
Jay Davis had the show right at the
parlor was really big for a long time
and Jays a great guy and puts on great
shows and we go over there
dude it was probably three or four women
that I met in there who were kept women
who had nice houses around there never
could explain what they did
always on jets doing this and that what
the [ __ ] you know so they didn't tell
you this and Mubeen but then later I
would hear from their friends
oh she's you know she's got a boyfriend
you know but he comes in once a month
there's something like that there's 60
year old guy from Texas it's a girl I
saw last night that I used to bang a
little bit and you know do things and
everything with each other's bodies and
she said uh she said oh she got this guy
she says it's her Godfather she always
frames a mess you know doesn't even grow
so it's not really though but I just
realized the other day that's what the
[ __ ] going on I could there was always
an element missing as to where this girl
made any money how she was living lavish
in the hill and she always had this
Godfather you know and it didn't make
any sense then finally the other day I
realized oh that's the this the guy
there's no Godfather you know this is
the bank account you know that's the guy
remember and [ __ ] pretty women when
he says son you know why are you telling
on my Toby's my uncle yeah and he goes
don't worry about a lot of uncles come
in here and I could just see it it just
makes sense that's gross
that's what I told you Leo family mom
ago I told you that not a real family I
know but even acquainted with that with
the world
right my uncle oh that's my uncle you
gotta see that ball yeah this is my
lives my boss or something yeah can you
let me ask you this man when I was when
I was [ __ ] 20 that was nineteen Wow
I'll never forget walking around in this
summertime in Aspen never forget this
even Mike maybe because at that time I
was such a [ __ ] [ __ ] but I'll never
forget 1980 [ __ ] threw in ass Aspen
Colorado walking around that summer
eating like a sandwich outside when the
white bench and going you know if I was
21 and I was blond and that was hot I
mean spanking that and I had class like
I knew what a fork was my news yeah like
I knew different like Jeff is a shrimp I
would come up here man then [ __ ] from
November to April walk out of here with
ten G's away cuz I know
Texans when I used to work at the
Crestwood Hotel Texans would come in bro
and then you believe me in that they
would come in with their families late
you your wife and three [ __ ] kids
three little [ __ ] morons and the
first thing you do is you go up to the
[ __ ] Senate like most people I meet
you and uh whatever his [ __ ] name is
deal we're going man I need new skis hey
many a new jacket we get in our car go
to Glenwood Springs yeah because that's
the law right and everything is cheap
down there only idiots would buy [ __ ]
like when you go to snow mesmerizes ski
Aspen only you're a [ __ ] it's just
somebody drove it if a violation of
honor percent yeah it's like [ __ ]
you're paying out the ass but let me
tell you something guy money oil guys
from Texas will come you get a minute
you drive them you pick them up at the
airport drive and they give you a
hundred bucks at the door then they go
all done we're gonna check in our still
and we're gonna come right back we need
a ride up to sport Kaelin they did this
every year bro
you gave a right to sport Kaelin you
waited the guy would give his [ __ ]
wife a [ __ ] black whatever the
highest yeah an Express card she would
go into a bar and take you in there with
whatever what do you mean you ain't no
have a drink
in those days I used to drink guys
because Texans come up there yeah and we
were going to like a [ __ ] John
they've done this bar the Tao and have a
drink while his wife was across the way
that's more killing than he'd have to
eat but to my drink he'd have five hmm
and then he'd go over I'd go back to the
van he'd go over and spend I mean from
socks the salesmen they're [ __ ] the
best they sell you everything yeah these
Texans are coming and go give me the
best to the best yeah
you know we don't want it all on
thousands I baggles yeah forty thousand
dollars Lee in [ __ ] equipment you
drive it back or they fix the fear they
come back up to ski they pick it up they
do that for four [ __ ] days the kids
are the only ones that really skied cuz
mom and dad are in their [ __ ] 50 is
their drink I guess what happens when
they leave leave this [ __ ] they leave
this [ __ ] I don't yes they do yeah they
do
we're talking [ __ ] we're talking skis
made out of bone human slave femurs
[ __ ] tell me they were ghosts bellman
the reason why those people work at that
hotel like when I was working there in
1983 when I was working at the crest
with 1984 60 % of people in that hotel
lived off for the tips in the winter and
[ __ ] what people left in their rooms
yeah Theo von goes to it hits a [ __ ]
HBO special it has a TV show what kind
of party do you think Theo von is going
in it
the old ones gonna pay 20 Kate Quigley
twenty thousand light himself on fire
okay yeah here's twenty thousand just
like your [ __ ] heads on fire oh I'm
gonna beat your ass yeah you like the
premiere of the show quickly lights up
[ __ ] heads on fire we tape it you know
what he's gonna drop up there he's gonna
buy shirts and [ __ ] and he's gonna buy
20 bottles of [ __ ] the best vodka
what he doesn't drink stays in the room
what do you do leave
making eight bucks an hour you walk into
a room and there's three bottles of Dom
Perignon and six bar selling
unopened that's how you made your money
in those days
dummy [ __ ] ski boots and skis I got
given to me at that hotel and I would
give me to people when I would give them
away like bro what size boots you were
eight there you go
Joey Jesus citrus Jesus six on our boots
yeah I bought around the church you know
they did that every [ __ ] week so I
did and did these people come leave it
and come back next year and do it again
do it again
oh no God what are they gonna do bring
it home no we're gonna do we boil a dead
dinosaur sauce but one can apartment
there and and gonna [ __ ] leave an
airport and drop the shuttle [ __ ]
bucket orders noon accent Oh forgive me
I used to laugh at those tags I remember
one guy opening up a briefcase one day
in front of me um a taxon came in and he
wanted money or something put away like
jewelry and his safe he can't lay the
jewelry but in his briefcase mm-hmm he
had stacks like a drug bill he was no
[ __ ] drug dealer he's a white dude
they don't like a [ __ ] meet complete
yeah but when he came to Colorado bring
his meats to Colorado because he knew he
was going to Aspen for nights he was
gonna buy blow you how many times people
walked into rooms and Aspen and bumped
into a corner oil to blow or an 8-ball
but nobody [ __ ] wait made just to
come up to me nope scummy look give me
like a gram and a half of coke that they
found in the room yeah won't take that
[ __ ] back mm-hmm especially in New York
you can usually hit up uh uh somebody
that's cleaning the rooms or whatever
and ask them tell them when you get
there we used to do that do we get there
tell him we get there you find anything
good you know here's 40 bucks drop it
off by my room really no questions that
it really is crazy when you see the
amount of money some people had but
never know leave it at that age like
when I lived up there I was like I I was
a hot girl
twenty-one nobody knew me I came out
here from Jersey
captain light bro yeah real light you
know put an ad word mattered children
down valley got myself at who bro Valley
just a soft signal where a jingle bell
around your funny and believe Hank Oh
carry a piece in your purse make believe
a bodyguard dropped you off yeah
and after a while Aspen listen to me
brother as a young girl if you're
getting a nickel a [ __ ] nut job and
you're getting two nut jobs at night
three nights a week
what are you doing - nut jobs a week
that's a thousand dollars oh and some of
those taxes will come up missing you
know what little girl I hope I just give
you ten thousand dollars and you just
stay and polish this knob yeah three
days you get ten thousand my son here's
twenty five hundred go [ __ ] my son you
go home you disconnect the [ __ ]
service and then you come back to me
explain it with different color hair
that's slick those chicks asleep bro
okay because after a while they're just
worked employed they're just business
women they learned how to become a bit
at first looking when you going to a
strip club and you see the girls with
honcho the did the local drug dealer
yeah like last night there was a
shooting he had a club and like I don't
know some bum little [ __ ] town we
used to do comedy here in California a
it was something nobody yeah but it's
true those little [ __ ] homey towns or
they have that one Club deluxe and the
neighborhood drug dealers VIP and when
he comes in oh yeah crazy and they don't
know that this guy's a scab awful
[ __ ] society's ass he's not even
nobody I'm saying like at least if he
was the real kingpin he didn't really do
a joke or yeah he said he's got more
grams in his mother but he's [ __ ]
Kingslayer if something's got spunk
tattooed across his [ __ ] chest yeah I
don't even know it is that is that his
gang name is also a name for semen or
something you know so [ __ ] cool he
walks in and those little clubs like
that it's so weird out I love it you
know when you walk into like a strip
club you know the girls that they bought
into it like there's certain girls now
oh yeah
bought into it and then there's certain
girls that a [ __ ] professional
yeah they gave me at that club where I
went to
they got a bunch of knuckleheads but
there's a girl and when you see her walk
in this usually strolls if he's got a
clipboard
she works you it's a work job and yet
she'll let you [ __ ] stick four
fingers up a knuckle an [ __ ] but I'll
tell you what don't leave there with
your pop get sucked out yeah you don't
leave then oh man she was hot
but I did what for how much what am i a
[ __ ] idiot that means they got a
talent right that's the talent I don't
know I can't I can't
we're doing the same [ __ ] man with our
emotions though and I did the same [ __ ]
as a criminal dude if I had a nice
[ __ ] out show it to people every
night for a couple of young Warren how
many people how many times have you
heard somebody there's a couple people
are he hangs out with that they this
abroad or he hangs out with not date
length love wise but they're friends she
sells our underwears a sock she makes a
living
yeah if selling her bras her underwear
something somebody takes a bra and
sniffs a [ __ ] bra some dude bro or
even a woman or a kid it's it's I don't
you cannot get mad at a woman for doing
that oh yeah dude I used to add this
dude enough are in college named Nome
right everybody called him Nome nice
dude she was like a little but it wasn't
like a little person you know he was
just outside of that you know barely do
me man I barely made it just rockin that
cusp you know if I'd have been a
lifeguard at like a [ __ ] only pool you
know like he was just but also where you
had to also be little to work at the
place so like he was just like above and
he uh anytime he he broke up with a
chick he would wear their underwear
around his neck it was like his thing
right and he'd do that all summer by the
end of summer this dude would be running
around looking like a [ __ ] like he
just robbed a bank in a Wild West you'd
have like nine pairs of [ __ ] women's
underwear around his neck you know he
wouldn't take them off not for the
summer now in a winner he was fret you
could see his neck he was natural in the
winter but [ __ ] Joey's a hoarder
pizzas over here so he's [ __ ]
customizing a lasagna here on this new
Africa
but suit I didn't get to the story so
what happened was I'm very sorry to
interrupt just a buddy might want to
know when I was landing in Omaha even
bugging me again not tonight bro no
Jesus Christ you so surprised to see how
I live and then I'll have friends that
don't stop about a week ago I have this
dear friend uh-huh dear friend I'm
talking when I'm in the Salmons brain we
play basketball with him this brother
yeah dear friend he calls me like lame
it
I even mind me do me a favor you son
does something with webpages with
YouTube pages like that's what he does
yeah him in this part no taking YouTube
page next thing you're making $3 next
you know you're making $300,000 or teach
to kids you could say it that's what
they do right I said tell you something
give me a call and I'll hook him up with
Lee maybe he can help us out yeah no
worries
this happened 9:00 in the morning you
know at 12 o'clock I go to the jujitsu
and that's enough all sides right I
could sit there with two ten fingers at
my house waiting for people to call me
so was thinking about jujitsu I look
what they call everybody's let's call it
1157 I have nine missed calls from 1157
hun sure enough I got a call from the
Sun and then look it's 30 minutes later
the father calls me yeah do you know
that [ __ ] called me every 45
minutes me on the dot the rest of the
day talking about 7:00 I just wouldn't
even [ __ ] answer the phone because I
knew if I have son of the Father I was
gonna go over [ __ ] off oh I see her
saying so I did he stopped at some point
I got maybe am I gonna at 2:00 in the
morning he stopped how late I'm like in
the morning New Jersey tonight I get out
the next morning
then who love [ __ ] do you think [ __ ]
calls me in 1901 and I forgotten all
about the day before yeah like I was
involved in my day and I looked at the
phone and I just swing and I go hey do
me a favor you call me one [ __ ] time
this is a business phone don't have a
[ __ ] call me once then one [ __ ]
day and I just hung up on him and I
haven't heard from [ __ ]
yeah because no don't forget it definite
if you call me between 7:30 and 9:00
a.m. what the [ __ ] do you think I'm
doing there I may be on Twitter but my
four and a half year old is on the floor
over there paint that asking me [ __ ]
questions
yeah so if I pick up the phone you're
not gonna like the conversation you're
about to [ __ ] hear yeah so I don't
pick up the phone other respect out of
my people's I don't respect out of my
peeps I don't pick up the [ __ ] phone
yeah because she's right there
and if not I'm with her on the couch
watching [ __ ] whatever I dare you to
come to my house and answer the phone on
the couch or my daughter sitting next me
I dare you yeah
I dare you you have no idea what
decencies you look at you you ever see
the look at the Niro gives Val Kilmer
look at Val Kilmer gives that [ __ ]
these at the diner you a you [ __ ]
around in my house sit on the couch
while she's watching cartoons and I dare
you phone the ring I got the big your
ring is on okay if your ringer is on she
will give you a [ __ ] look like are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] turn that [ __ ] off
yeah there was a Denny's sitting next to
her and she was playing with a [ __ ]
Barbie doll and with two little shoes on
and the shoes kept falling give me a
favor give me the [ __ ] shoes we get
that we can walk into Denny's and sure
enough daddy a shoe fell off I know the
[ __ ] shoe was gonna fall off
I [ __ ] knew it if you follow up on
[ __ ] one I'm gonna shut off over here
and don't move so I go outside there's
the shoe in the middle of the [ __ ]
driveway a car drove over it
poor Barbie shoes all [ __ ] up now I
gotta bring it into the cellar too and
I'll put it back on the foot the shoe is
so [ __ ] up mommy was limping
so we sit there my little business and
who walks in out of all the seats not
the [ __ ] place is empty
they got me waiting there cuz my wife
went back to the [ __ ] car for the
house because she forgot that if you
lock the door cela who walked in sila no
no no no no no no see lo I would if I
thought if I walked in that and that
[ __ ] Denny's I saw will you with me
when we saw what's-his-name in there I
don't think so yeah you we saw was they
got the brains was improvement Oh till
he goes there all the time
that's a swing and Eddie's over there
yeah I just don't go in there and like
this that's your board they get shot
when you go to Denny's after 10:00
nowadays you might as well sign up for
the next country [ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ]
them whatever stand real close to the
window wave this time dude this row I
used to do this vid about Denny's how
much I ate at Denny's right
it's AM especial right so anyway I was
like I wish somebody would shoot up a
[ __ ] dead he's right that's what I
would say dude some kid puts in the
comments he goes man he puts a call a
link to a YouTube clip he goes man my
dad actually got shot up at a [ __ ]
tennis because somebody walked him with
a gun it shot everybody in the place one
star but I still love this yeah I am
joking about it he said it really
happened he lost his father right next
to a [ __ ] grill bro right next to a
griddle you know what you got you know
two brothers back there if I can
sword fighting with spatulas horribly
hopped up on [ __ ] that's a betta
means you know not knowing their job
[ __ ] Mexican guys sitting at the bar
you know unbelievable man but that's god
dude that kid came and he was just
positive man just a couple places where
I go late night and I'm like like one
night melee and Becky went to Denny's on
a fun on a [ __ ] Sunday night after a
podcast and we were having a good time
but the whole
I was like squatting under the bush by
that window because the windows on
Burbank Boulevard yeah I want to be a
[ __ ] alright shoot up a Denny's I'm
sitting there having [ __ ] a salad and
something with my friend and Becky's
sitting counterclockwise so she gets it
right now we gotta bury Becky with a
[Laughter]
it's good you see me how many nights we
leave here dying of hunger you and I
1:00 in the morning sometimes me enemy's
cross-eyed yeah this guy if I head to of
the morning if I gonna lean listen I got
a cent a sandwich coming over here just
jiggle my ball I already see how
confusing for ten minutes it'll be
sitting there confused all I had this
gigolos ball
I washed my hands I've done worse I got
a [ __ ] really oh my god oh my god this
fart is tremendous this is dick bro they
had a guy used to tell us write me give
you 30 bucks just to tell you he'd been
jerking off this older dude I don't know
when I was young he just said I'd be
like look I'm gonna tell you something
all right
it was like all right and he'd say I've
been jerking off give me 30 bucks
knowing then he would give us 30 bucks
to keep quiet good lord we were children
maybe one person be saying it to us Oh
you paid you yeah I'm not paying him for
him to tell me that [ __ ] you don't go oh
[ __ ] I assumed that when I met him but
here was the thing though I never even
got to this do was that so my sister one
time we lived together for a while right
and this is probably about eight years
ago she had this other dancer to work
with her came over to our place right
stole our vacuum
shoes on these kelana pants and
everything and then she got all [ __ ]
you know warm under the skin one night
on him pills we [ __ ] stole our vacuum
No and as you do I wasn't there when she
stole it but literally I could pitch her
probably trying to put it in her [ __ ]
purse you know like the stick end in the
first of the [ __ ] huge vacuum hanging
out right do fast-forward year and a
half right I might even live with my
sister anymore I'm in New Orleans for a
bachelorette party or somewhere the
Baton Rouge somewhere about a bachelor
party they got a big [ __ ] money deal
right they wheeling one of those cakes
where the women pop out like the fake
cake and they pop out and they dance
right you know one of the chicks that
pops out is the [ __ ] [ __ ] that stole
my vacuum bro right so everybody else I
have no idea I totally forgot about this
Oh everybody else is tipping these
[ __ ] and [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
shaking both of their ass cheeks at the
same time you know with each hand you
know like they're you know like doing a
really fast yeah and Here I am in the
background at all I can think is that
[ __ ] stole my [ __ ] vacuum dude bro I
had half of a nerve to just the whole
time to speak vacuum sounds in the back
just like
what is so pissed bruh what'd you do
what'd she tell you huh what did she do
when she acted like she didn't know and
that's the thing I don't like about
people I guess that steel vacuums is
when they see you they act like you
don't [ __ ] remember like I'm not gonna
remember you stole a vacuum for I was in
all Kalon offense I wasn't on so as you
know how do you get away with a vacuum
like doesn't someone if they reckon if I
was in an apartment building I saw
someone who was on like Kawana pins with
a vacuum I'm just running down the
stairs bless you
that's half of America it's happened a
neighborhood what can they give you for
[ __ ] back you I mean if you came on
my hospital vacuum okay give me the
small 50 no I don't know what if it goes
kaput after they go down a block I'm no
[ __ ] vacuum mechanic but I thought
there's a little [ __ ] belt in there
and whenever that when you hit something
[ __ ] up the belt breaks like I used to
have a Kirby vacuum and they come with a
package as a belt I couldn't do it
whenever the vacuum broke my mom and I
take it out off and put the vacuum on
yeah there's got to be like a [ __ ]
technician you gotta unplug it or the
vacuum will suck your fingers in [ __ ]
got a great Cuban can't fix a vacuum my
mom could take the thing we had a Kirby
we were good when I was a kid they had
like this shitty vacuum is you could buy
yeah my mom was such a [ __ ] speck she
was such a [ __ ] neurotic Cuban that
she blowed she she bought a vacuum like
let's say a back vacuum in those days
like a top-notch vacuum caused
14.95 and yes I can this set well a boy
he was 73 once we move back to click on
Kirby I soon to vacuum one little kick
on Kirby vacuums when you could I still
gonna be the kid and and the guy coming
over to the house and my mom and her
girlfriend I'm like a buddy were over
and I'm like what's going on a lot more
expensive than $15 now how much no no
what I said that if a regular vacuum
cost 15 bucks in those days this was a
yardstick gotcha put it on put another
thing there like if this was like it
came I got a when it came to
house in those days at toy stores if you
walked inside to James Bond aisle
well the coolest toys of the 70s was you
got a briefcase yeah
okay there's briefcase Lee check this
out there was this briefcase as a child
okay that's for like how do I leave
knowing the course I don't
that's the why we get into prices
briefcases for children there was a
briefcase it was a plastic briefcase
yeah I wanted to be a secret agent right
and it was based after James Bond that
couldn't say double-oh-seven on it you
ready Lee and on this suitcase it the
cool thing about the suitcase is then it
had a button on the handle right see to
press the button and a plastic bullet
would come out and shoot out because and
there was a gun with a silencer I
connected to this hinge ER it was wrong
you don't for 10 year olds yeah oh for
children you want to be an [ __ ] yeah
you know I thought this is something up
and go and then with it in the chest you
go [ __ ] yeah you would have the
same gun I was a bank robber but then
there came like handcuffs a rope like
all secret ages yeah telesco magnifying
glass yeah so my point is um when my mom
showed me when this guy came over mm-hmm
what what God was so cool about Kirby
vacuum cleaners at the time with that it
came in a [ __ ] box hmm
and it can't see how all those utensils
are yeah like all those utensils right
there for the four for the four 29:1
yeah that [ __ ] vacuum had a beautiful
case mmm that you opened up and or
everything was neat nice and neat yeah
so we had a Kirby vacuum growing up and
that was nice it's nice yeah I see your
house was always clean look you had all
the brushes all the things for the
furniture see the belts who the [ __ ] do
you think you're dealing with do you
think you got thank you [ __ ] guys the
[ __ ] dealing will you see a little
circle because arrest let's say there's
a [ __ ] downstairs you know save
that's what happened the Kirby vacuum
should be getting a Vig for these
[ __ ] that wear these braces to put
you know yeah help the [ __ ] homeless
and uh I think sharks water for the
blind and [ __ ]
I wouldn't know an artifact that no it's
a bin listen when the thing breaks it's
real [ __ ] it easy I was just done you
take off the grill Bob you take it off
the loop okay and then you will you take
the old the old one up snap and you
think if I take a rubber band and cut it
with a scissor it just snaps it's just
one should one rope then you take that
and you loop it on something and you
loop it back on the thing you close the
vacuum and your thing is tip-top moon
geun so I can't believe that they still
didn't take away their loot you people
think I'm moving and dropping knowledge
with no [ __ ] knowledge if I tell you
about Kirby vacuum it's because [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] not what I run the plant is
used to just be so much more hearty
brother the vacuum you could ride on the
[ __ ] vac you remember that you were a
little kid you could sit on there where
your mom was pushing a ride I like it
was like a piece of [ __ ] metal I love
vacuuming you know this day I vacuumed
it that I love there's something
soothing about it something about vac I
don't like when it's too like my wife
she's part of the [ __ ] technology
world so we got a vacuum take Mose by
itself no no nothing's a piece of [ __ ]
the [ __ ] vacuums got a thousand
things I'm scared to [ __ ] touch it
yeah and she's got a rug cleaner cuz the
cat piss everywhere yeah so we gotta
have a [ __ ] rug cleaner constantly
would help but clean the rugs dump just
people's feet just us walking around
with sneakers can you a man
your house is filthy filthy late if you
don't mop like with a hot hot water
every week you know we lay down on [ __ ]
we try to sell so much stuff it's not us
it's not us it's when we walk to our
cars it's all that [ __ ] that we step on
you walk in and out of your house every
day like yeah that was looking at you
ever have a wall that's a turn-on the
[ __ ] light your finger always hits
the head there's always your fingers and
the roughs
even though you wash your hands druggers
whatever SEMA not again no there's
nothing like that on my walls with wa4
don't stand on your hand when you touch
the light picture think about a light
picture think about everybody's grow
saying muffin pieces a little piece of
muffin
you know sugars
see definitely see many people that
[ __ ] semen all over their house your
uh I I worked in a restaurant so they
make you go through like training for
that stuff yeah I fit whatever member
somewhere and you need to get a soda lid
I never grabbed the one on top I always
go in I never grab the first straw I
hate I hate cyclase it that there's
places that have just loose straws not
even with plastic around them I won't go
there sweetie they get the paper
old school paper in here yeah I don't
like that but I remember I was talking
about this earlier the kid like when the
Halloween when I was young came on the
weekend we didn't hang gonna poison took
a tree pen
Robin little kids for bags do we had
they didn't have the individually
wrapped candies I remember this one
house we went to and their grandfather
had died they [ __ ] his grandfather
died on Halloween they left him out on
the porch for the night brother how
[ __ ] awesome is that right knowing
that he's dead anyway right but
sometimes these houses would have people
think it was a decoration or something
people thought he was just being scared
and resting but but this is when he died
and that's when he left the earth was on
Halloween right but this is a time when
you would get I know this one house the
candy was all junked in the bowl like
they didn't weren't all individually
wrapped candies you know what I'm saying
I'm going to replace a just put the
whole mints in there and there but all
and one person will just get the whole
[ __ ] Rock a mint you know so you're
running around with like 300 minutes on
your arm in one chunk you know she came
home with some kid that we did two or
three things she came home with some
candy but I'll tell you something like
three or four people gave her little
bottles of water I can't wait till she
gets old look so she throws them back at
the [ __ ] pier and go get your life
together give her water water to a child
was sure that I rain it that thing the
first night Friday night when I got home
I got stoned by mistake and I started
eating little licorice isn't she'll like
three of them in there
she's pissed well she knew huh like ya
do did you look through it like what
when I was gonna houses first off we
went to the church and we went to the
Squatch and they have a thing called
trunk-or-treat and people pull their
cars it back there people that are
involved with the school and parents so
kids can't even go to houses anymore
no we're going to do that on Tuesday
gotcha yeah this is for little kids and
whatever what's gonna happen is we hide
uh she's Tuesday she's got like [ __ ]
swimming you know she don't get out of
that till 5:30 we're gonna bring a whole
by the time we get home
in fact I money everywhere late yeah
we'll be running late because we're
gonna [ __ ] bring a home for uh the
heat and some of you'll ring the
doorbell once the kids come she's the
last year she just closed she goes mommy
daddy bye we hadn't run out after last
year Wow if she just took off with the
other [ __ ] kids like she was like so
you and I'm willing what the [ __ ] you do
this can't be out there to get in so we
walked oh it got dark then she's like
mom dad let's get the [ __ ] out last
night she told my wife let's get out and
they went to trick-or-treat at the
church my wife should have to me let's
go it's good to go yeah at least she
knows what's up but yeah they got out
they used to have we went the houses we
knocked on people's doors they gave you
pennies nickels they give you big pieces
of chocolate [ __ ] touch the popcorn
chunks of popcorn [ __ ] food sugar one
lady she is like a [ __ ] two things of
sugar and [ __ ] this was scoops [ __ ]
no case he's not even a sentence today
I've [ __ ] half of [ __ ]
oh damn give your kids dick the reason
why I asked you earlier if it bothered
you is because when I was growing up I
had a dear dear dear friend that I bean
Giovanni was a sweetheart beautiful
[ __ ] young kid and he had three
sisters all of them like each one of a
beauty queens got one that one of those
families we had it was him and a brother
and six sisters but all of them like
even the 10 year old you like Jesus he
[ __ ] the whole family did your parents
do yeah
every one of these guards a dragon-like
the second oldest one went to dance but
this was the [ __ ] up day she danced to
blocks of my house like with the weeks
it was out and you know you'd be at the
[ __ ] liquor store with him waiting
for something to buy you booze and
somebody would come up to you nobody
guys do it for nothing
let's go down at Tina's dance and Tina
was his [ __ ] sister
well you know what I would feel like my
heart would [ __ ] stop and there were
nights that I heard that he actually
went down and pulled her out of there by
a [ __ ] hair and [ __ ] yeah there was a
couple incidents with him he was a good
kid I mean look I I don't think I was
extolled about it for sure right you
were jumping up and down look I know the
childhood that we had you know and I
know I got very little connection like
with any you know I didn't have any
guidance or connection so I know she got
even less than that you know she was you
know the youngest kid in our family so
and I didn't feel like I knew her well
enough or had enough pull you know
emotional connection with her - she was
gonna listen to me you know so and what
am I gonna you know like so all I could
do was just be supportive
you know taught it makes fishy warsi but
when she drove make sure she was we know
walking with people in and out of these
clubs and also my sister was a smart she
wasn't a [ __ ] putz you know she was a
smart girl she still is a smart girl I
wonder what you can make as a [ __ ]
she bought a house I mean she bought a
beautiful son Arizona like that's it
that's it that's the proof of the
pudding because if you're [ __ ] smart
and then they get to be [ __ ] slick
like when I live in Seattle
my girlfriend was a [ __ ] half a
stripper she had the mind of I mean
she's as dumb as a box around yeah she's
a millionaire yeah she ends up marrying
a Hindu that was 80 he died the whole
[ __ ] deal the [ __ ] dying I do try
nice guy you know but let me tell you
something man
man not to admit from [ __ ] 95 to 97
that girl supported me yeah she was
making it Bank yeah and I couldn't walk
tired oh hey how did you make this extra
two hundred [ __ ] business yeah you
know it's none of my [ __ ] business
but I don't know a lot of people make
jokes about strippers and cooling me I
got the utmost respect for them because
it's a deep game well look I mean I'm
it's a deep [ __ ] game dawg dude I
hooked up with a stripper in Shreveport
that looked like a half of um what is a
minute or a senator which one that have
an animal for the half lower body I
think both of those yeah I think I look
like a centaur you know but she still
seemed cool she was
I swear to god she had the strongest
[ __ ] in she had thighs for calves she
had thighs up top and then also double
thighs no calves you know like just
built like a damn [ __ ] you know like
ice like a squirrel squats just like
[ __ ] short thick [ __ ] legs you
know all stomach hardly any legs our
arms but I'll tell you this dude I
I notice and here's what I notice I find
that comedians are often in we fall in a
lot of same circles as like porn stars
exotic dancers because there's some
similarities know we're broken that the
similarity is that somewhere we feel
shortened somewhere along yeah we need
some type of immediate acceptance like I
sit here sometimes at night and then
that here but many nights have sat dance
and why did I become a comedian I mean
that I need attention when I was a kid
my mom was on my ass when I was a kid
yeah but on your ass and me and making
you feel loved or two different things
no but it was the same thing it's not
like I sat there and you know [ __ ] no
no no she has always know that's one
thing I lack the love of a father right
you know so maybe that sparked exam one
bro but I mean do you think that maybe
she was loving for the first I think
what you were 13 15 15 6 so maybe maybe
if she had
had lived you wouldn't have been a
comedian so maybe from the love that you
lost I always loved performing when I
was a kid I was kind of musician mm-hmm
and then as I got older I did karate but
my specialty was deformed and I was
really gonna do it Forbes and putting
together stupid moves and [ __ ] and then
I heard stand-up comedy and I just
thought it was [ __ ] superb and I
thought I became whatever the [ __ ] I
ended up becoming yeah and now we're
here you know so somewhere
I took different elements of that
childhood huh and I became a stand-up
comic do I Drive a fancy car do I
[ __ ] jump up and down and jiggle for
love at this point man laughs you know
me a long time bro I got my own views I
live my own [ __ ] life I don't give a
[ __ ] about what you know directors and
producers pick before you came in you're
a [ __ ] man and you gotta leave here
[ __ ] man yeah if you become what they
want you to become those are the [ __ ]
people that they love she'll never came
here
they never should have came here yeah
what those stories I told last night at
the Ice House on stage they're true
stories I told you gotta go [ __ ] himself
on the set of this [ __ ] high line
commercial yeah like I shot this Arby's
what is it again are you sure you're
missing it no what's it even kill
parties parties well I love Hardee's
broth so they were the cousin to
Hardee's I'll call Jen cause Julia sold
years ago Bryce shot three national
commercials three weeks in a row like in
my 20 years here that's he had look like
ten commercials but in 2009 2001 of
those years I booked a [ __ ] three
national sprint Wow something else and
this Arby's which was [ __ ] money yeah
because they pay you from both companies
then they baked my ads together you have
no [ __ ] idea Lee did I did a shitty
internet commercial one time I made 25
grand over 30 years bro I'm lazy how
many people stay in the front of a cup
of 7-eleven 25 grand over three years is
a gift oh it was cry
kanessa give my couldn't imagine I
thought was gonna be $600 you know I
could never imagine that what I made
down with 20 over that time oh yeah and
they give you a little right totally for
a year now leap stop this [ __ ] go get
your headshots go give that guy's go to
Aqua tell them you want to go out for
commercials Jesus Christ put you in some
[ __ ] Hershey Kisses snacks anything that
people he jumping up and down gather the
jersey on you're gonna do you know
you're Zombo looking [ __ ] you
say yeah you could be a friend that he's
not gonna know fat of chips bra your
pocket dog guarding the condiments dude
or [ __ ] sitting there with some [ __ ]
on your leg it's I love that somebody
told somebody said the minute they stop
going off with the at you and then just
focus on commercial I was like you know
what I think it's time for uncle Joey to
get me commercial agent again yeah
because I'm gonna book a mafia
commercial once a year or a cook or a
chef or a pizza guy or a garbage man
yeah if you know if you're not in the
game you're never gonna book the game
yeah I signed with a chick and a week
let I get paperwork but I got to put my
bank account information on there I go
what do you need my background
information for she goes well if we ever
need together Dennis you gotta take that
off the contract pop it just gives you a
name and a headshot go to work [ __ ]
yeah and then we'll worry about [ __ ]
bank information social security numbers
suck my dick I gotta give you a credit
report or [ __ ] you let me see your
credit report [ __ ] cooler it's [ __ ]
people yelled a sleazy fiood out of
these people with Tony Bennett
[ __ ]
they [ __ ] people let me see your
[ __ ] credit report animals brah let
me see your [ __ ] credit report
[Music]
[ __ ] balls up people I wanna be round
sounds good up to pick up the pieces I
don't know why every time we're fighting
I can save you guys like a shield the
best that can look inside of my [ __ ]
it's like right my [ __ ] would sink
the whole candle factory this was
chicken Florentine that my wife made for
this song to do oh that food yeah man
I've been eating some plants recently
sorry I'm gonna have it any gas man to
what
I farted the other day and forgot I had
it farted a long time okay that's the
number one thing I think I'm gonna miss
when I die brought farting probably and
looking at horses I thought veggies made
you fart all the time not me man you
clean you're sober you look good you
know a dog gonna shoot a special what do
you wanna do I think we're gonna do one
or so time we'll see if that dog listen
you see that Adam right there
yeah what's his name he said please hold
a bunch of us and you know what bro you
can't yourself with only a couple of
Dimes we put together a little team you
take it to the Irvine improv we blow it
up on a few podcasts do it ice house and
you do two shows it doesn't matter
material material guess who owns the
material who's got the money on [ __ ]
light tones yeah you do when you monitor
it and you know what this whole business
is mean anyway how many people have free
internet and how many people have show
to him that's let's take a [ __ ] boat
yeah I'm saying so if it's gonna be show
time we gonna say yourself for show time
[ __ ] it you know what let me go let me
put a [ __ ] how about you put pictures
in there you light in case a soul on
fire yeah you with your buddies at The
Comedy Store wall come down to support
you
doing the night overall in town people
rather have that and a [ __ ] CD and
guess what you're the Captain Kirk of
the enterprise and you run a because you
know these people don't listen to you at
work and left their ass off
yeah more than it's happened to Showtime
go and all yeah I agree
you're making them go to places they
ain't there and you know what they love
you to dead man he with the Showtime
[ __ ] him yeah I'll go to somebody who's
on iTunes for 2050 2 sides and I can
listen to our work and giggle and what
about the video could we also put the
video on iTunes you think Lee yeah
absolutely you can do whatever the [ __ ]
you want with the video I'd rather you
control it I'd rather you pay that's
what I think
well baby G don't let them get the video
then pay another number and let them get
a a G note and let them get the video
and the behind-the-scenes with Lee and
us and smoking reefer you going home is
showing your father's grave and you
bowing and yeah let's go show me the
camper will your sister strip the first
time and Loki's gonna see what that no
one said that loved a seal in there that
dead devout put a bunch of surfers
stripper nananana Batman suck my dicks
like my [ __ ] make my day man
that'd be TVP wait what were some of
your Halloween costumes when you were
young dude one of them was probably
Batman you couldn't even have a [ __ ]
a Boy Scout couldn't even be next to me
cuz those in those days you were
flammable as [ __ ] when I was a kid
people used to light on fire all the
time but no [ __ ] reason go to school
on a Tuesday the next day they come in
with bandages and a jar full of Vaseline
no eyebrows will happen to you were you
letting people on fire no just a wild
night dude listen if the car was driving
okay people don't really come bus
obvious they did buy those suits they
were made by some material kerosene I
dog this [ __ ] was blowing up so let's
say you were walking with me you see oh
we got a couple of idiots with ten we're
walking across the street with our
little [ __ ] and there's people who make
costumes yeah but then there were
parents who warned them they came in a
box and they came with a madman top of
the [ __ ] Masek cut your [ __ ] yeah the
mass would cut your skin it was like
razor blades it was for tough kids yeah
and then the suit you were gonna live
when your mom gave you
she signs them for liberty national
insurance because let me say let me put
to this really you crossing the street
you got the hand that goes like this you
know right right but at that first light
there's a car and my mistake it's like
an illegal 1966 year Val if it backfires
you're going up with Frank him say did
they had some textiles going around our
area that I caressed I wish Lee I was
lying in kerosene in the cloth yeah
you'll burn he'll burn every Christmas
you see a group of kids one of them her
like a flash soon a black man you like
that kids like no other school little
mom yeah
somewhere along the line those poor
bastards were [ __ ] combust Chevy
blazes would always do a fire off to at
the end you know my uncle used to get
out with one bench in the back of the
car and they would go off and he would
act like it shot him you know and he'd
fall on the ground because a lot of this
cars would backfire and they had a lot
of clothing back in our area somebody's
making bad clothing i kerosene in it and
kids were [ __ ] getting uh adult still
a lot of adult man we were smokers were
getting [ __ ] hilarious I forgot all
about those [ __ ] in the boxes I forgot
about them you forgot about the box they
and they had all different sizes all
different colors and they were called
take your chance Halloween make it a
real Halloween making the brownie only
the other days people want a bit scary
you want to be on only shove a dick and
yes and get a mirror in front of your
face and look at the reflection of your
mouth open you'll be scared what the
states where they endorse [ __ ] you they
endorsed [ __ ] now what do you call
those people they enjoin flammable
people yeah they enjoy jealous we're
like you took your head dude they had a
girl and her dude she put that mask on
in her head was so big it would like
smash her face you know like a shape of
like a cookie right and it would take
three days even after she took the mask
off it would take like three days for
her [ __ ] face to go back to [ __ ]
past look like Mickey Rooney dude this
girl look like [ __ ] with Mickey
Rooney
my I told you when I was growing up you
were growing up every day you live for
you you you struggle for your life
whether you were rich or nut cuz those
are the kids who want those little half
of facts which one will those kids that
had the flammable [ __ ] Batman suits
and [ __ ] the kids that just like I put a
sheet on my head one year yeah you know
whatever everybody's a [ __ ] ghost I'm
gonna lose it
one year I was a garbage man when he has
a [ __ ] the boys shoot him
I'm a [ __ ] stool on but yeah you put a
sheet over the end or the [ __ ] hanger
around you know you know like a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah like an Italian nun yeah so that
that's what you know so that was the
[ __ ] story I dressed up or I had
probably got dressed up [ __ ] four
times and fifty four [ __ ] years yeah
I was a little big Halloween dude that
dressing up [ __ ] scares me
yeah this week scares the [ __ ] out being
man Wednesday's DLO mortos no Cemetery
yeah you people be you people do it the
right way you go up there you think
somebody's going to come out with a boom
bass I think I go deep into the Voodoo
world yeah I go deep I don't like
candles up in the cigar out I'll
probably put some Cuban food out for
these [ __ ] spirits this week is drums
crazy I got some guineas on there I got
to take care of I got I got a meatball
from rael I got some Irish peopIe gotta
put a shot of whiskey out you got the
all please yeah I have the [ __ ] nah
the [ __ ] altar for you people who
[ __ ] kept you alive over the years a
lot of I got Bolzano Rago
table especially ow I got [ __ ] uh
Jesus my mother my father my godmother I
got there's a writer
my stepfather he could burn in hell I
don't give a [ __ ] about no come on
yeah yeah I don't toast them for Dickie
Moore I used to toast Oh give him a
dollar son you can just toast so many
people you know I'm saying I got people
dying left and running a Ralphie now I
gotta get a picture of Ralphie and put
like a [ __ ] jalapeno popper I'll
respect for that [ __ ] [ __ ] left
me here with these [ __ ] Gentiles
kowtow oh I had a rough time
nights podcast because he showed up to
the office D on that Wednesday night yes
we heard we heard the hordes go papa
we're talking about him papa papa we
were talking about him I know you know
game is sadly that speaker he gave it to
me wow look how long ago was it we by
that company that you get a magazine
showroom and sharper image oh yeah yeah
my house in a box I didn't even know
what the [ __ ] it was I know honey I got
this in the mail honey she goes Ralphie
sucker T it's a iPad iPod charger I
still got the I'm so old school I still
got that iPod I brought that here cuz
the speakers are sensational and right
as we were talking about it you felt
like a little breeze and all of a sudden
I could feel I can just remember him he
was just dead three [ __ ] weeks ago
four weeks ago sitting there and the
[ __ ] Mexican fruit guy came he goes
mama Papa but Papa Papa and Ralphie
always would go pick up a pie epping a
papaya for years Ralphie's been saying
that [ __ ] whenever you play that denim
and yeah first of all everything he said
is exactly how in town but also we're
here every night
that truck cats that sound is never here
that's always it we came by to say
goodbye that's reality guys they stick
around for 30 days they just don't go
into [ __ ] the next image they want to
see your friends one last time and touch
it and listen Brian a friend Jimmy
Buerkle that I loved then I get getting
the call from him on that Friday he was
the hospital already
names like Cox what's happening I could
tell his voice he was done he had
thought we would wrestle we can tears
and I didn't forget getting a call that
Sunday saying he died Sunday morning and
[ __ ] he was saying you're buying man
with carmine Bolzano died I missed his
call when I called him back he was dead
Wow
a day later strike he calls he goes yeah
your phone you just called them he must
have just gone to the bathroom got up
and died of a heart attack
and they call you to say goodbye at
Lisa's goodbye believe it enough they
all say goodbye in their own way
and if you talk to people who have had
somebody dying recently who give them 30
days they give you a signal before they
leave just to let you know that they got
your back it's the weirdest thing about
life hmm yeah I believe that man they'll
give you and I know it sounds crazy I'm
talking about flats and whatever I'm
talking about the spiritual world I was
raised in it so I get it I believed that
my dad opens up a lot of doors for me
and closed a lot of doors I was there a
lot of nights man with a lot of choices
to run and I always made the right
choice and then I wouldn't be in this
[ __ ] champ something makes you make
the right choice yeah something
something everything in life sometimes
you ever you ever watch that voice -
movie The Shining yeah The Shining when
scatman Brothers talks a little boy
the explains to him that everybody hears
that voice let's call this you know a
limiter I don't remember that part I
gotta watch it again only seen it one
time cuz that's the shiny Scatman
Crothers talks to a little boy yeah and
you'll see you have 15 minutes we gotta
get you outta here so and you would obey
you travelin plan what am i doing me in
my world brother you're gonna be one of
the next [ __ ] top [ __ ] comics in
this country and I tell you this is your
older brother and I got no jealousy I
wish you all you stand the right track
tell your agent to push you out for more
movies and TV yeah stop [ __ ] around
you want to be a host go somewhere else
butter Germany and host Nazi videos and
be really appreciated man you always is
so supportive agent spirally said acting
ability a little acting resume yeah
you're gonna stay on the road to you 93
miles will take a gamble you know look
at the paycheck from the acting you know
what am I gonna do with this uncle Joey
because they might like it and it might
use just six times this one ten it's not
a lot of money but now you're building
credibility in next gen BC thinks things
to you for this new fireman show
they're looking for a handsome guy from
the south and Bank may you go old Jed's
a millionaire so now what do you shoot
10 episode then you're gonna get rich no
really
but you got comedy in your building and
you get your podcast and you got Twitter
you're very funny
it all comes at you yeah I know you're
on the road killing I hear people
[ __ ] love you even saying
staying busy we gotta fit you got to
figure we gotta figure out how to get
them to those Thursday night to suck you
a little nut sack I said I'm saying brah
cause I'm bringing my I see you at the
school I see at the store here put that
on the table you never saw this did you
Lee oh yeah dude no you didn't come you
don't tell you go flying watch this
scary [ __ ] that Arsenio
it is it is Lee no it's not yeah it is
it was this haircut
do you know how I knew your name was
dark
you know what I'm talking about don't
you
I can remember when I was a little boy
my grandmother and I could hold
conversations entirely without ever
opening our mouths she called it shiny
hmm
and for a long time I thought it was
just the two of us that had the shine to
us just like you probably thought he was
the only one but there are other folks
though mostly they don't know it or
don't believe it
that's why kid isn't trust him I know he
knows what the [ __ ] he's saying cuz
nobody thought I was done
why did you want to talk about it and
not supposed to lose edge ain't supposed
to
Tony hmm who's Tony solo boy was my
mouth
damn nope that's 20 to 1 damn tells you
things yes
how does he tell you things
it's like I gonna sleep and he shows me
things but when I wake up every room
everything what's the matter Lee Turner
please get nervous this when you work in
everybody has an imaginary friend that
friend is an ancestor talking to you're
talking to you ancestor you never even
know it
yeah you leave anything on ancestry.com
yeah the stratum as you grow up you
build out your confidence man yeah it's
kind of weird it's a weird [ __ ] thing
because I see it now at mercy we might
talk to us you for [ __ ] it's gonna be
five in two months you see yeah the
whole thing you say what's the matter we
don't like those type of movies no I
don't like this can't have a little
issue there is yeah well they play that
[ __ ] music to make you nervous yeah
and then it's talking about [ __ ]
craziness yeah oh sure but even back
then race relations wasn't that good
even if you've watched a [ __ ] video
that's a great [ __ ] movie and that
movie that's a real movie because it
scares the [ __ ] down here without
scaring the [ __ ] out of yeah that's some
well that's a real director right there
that's a film that you know though watch
generations in film school don't wanna
be scare you without scaring you he
doesn't [ __ ] with you till the end who's
the director of that I think cuz we
gotta be Stephen King yes he's the best
King is the writer
I'm the [ __ ] you know I'm saying
everything Cooper I don't know been one
of those crazy [ __ ] you think
we're gonna be New Year's Eve me nowhere
man you still open I got one set yeah I
got one I'm gonna be in Huntsville
Alabama in November 16th 18th and 19th
and where the [ __ ] is that you have to
fly into Nashville I don't know yeah you
have to [ __ ] look I think you have to
fly international connect and get a
rental car I heard that yeah that's why
if you have to get a rental car
I don't know from water hoods well I
might just get one L I got family down
there so yeah I don't like driving those
[ __ ] distances well no wonder [ __ ]
I'm going yes probably got a three hour
drive and guess I'm from one of the big
ones yeah
[ __ ] Lexington they got an airport
I like Lexington I love that clubs great
right I still got the leak in the
ceiling of it in the club is great great
good the [ __ ] town is beautiful it's
a cool town people think it's not bad
it's diverse it's cool it's hit me my
wife been thinking about a lot of things
and that's I love you get you some
horses out there I like the [ __ ]
sound man I still want to raise my
daughter in some place where it's
[ __ ] normal yeah don't stay Nashville
is good man I mean I think Robbie was
onto something with Nashville now it was
beautiful Ralphie was definitely on for
some million dollars you get you a
beautiful place out there yeah a billion
dollars from me that was out there that
comes with two Butler's one of them is
Vegas yeah what a rubbish it down sticks
a finger in your ass when is your ass
you got a bell in your bathroom imagine
having a bell in your bathroom
and somebody comes in without a [ __ ]
mask on it just wipes your face like a
soldier with a smile on their face have
you seen the YouTube video of Liam outer
space obviously yeah you put it up for
you boy just fake it thinking look at
this face when he first saw it he said
there goes my job career listen you're
29 Snoop Dogg became a legend from
smoking oh you're the [ __ ] human
pectoral bra you are one of the funniest
dudes around me your names will have
picked you from the [ __ ] choir caps
proud as I do it I looked at you and
they knew you were shy no [ __ ] deal
and then you just needed somebody to
push you over to clean your chain you
growing out he goes from shout outs
right into my buddy Matt hold up my
brother Matt home Maya having a hard
time over that putting the pieces
together Dennis hi well
brother and nephew Bablu Lingus Niki
campus life Mickey chaps hallo Z Alex
Nikki shades fat Chris blow chair and
Kaylie you know I love you [ __ ]
don't forget the funny bone omaha
thursday friday saturday and don't
forget i told you this one don't forget
I told you got them for shows me and
Dean Delray Friday the 10th and Saturday
11th don't [ __ ] around anyway you got
any dates to promote my brother I got
lost when I'm be dropping on these
people is the church I got it baby want
to see your baby boy let's do this [ __ ]
coming to confess maybe I had November
16th through the 19th at stand-up live
in Huntsville Alabama there you go right
there come on support this service let
them know you're part of the church
don't do some B's family here keep it
low and I mean good memory
if you gotta first if you got an a a
book give it to God don't whine the
evils will hit me where it hurts
and I'm in Calgary December 1st and I
got um and I got my podcast this past
weekend you can check out when you're
done checking out Joey for you comic
started struggling with any addiction
think about this young man hit me about
me he took over he banged the [ __ ]
stripper in a cab he changed his life he
went to church he met a friend they went
together and look in him 18 months he
looks good he's still funny gotta be I
think if I please stop getting drunk my
friends won't like me if you open mic
thing you need new [ __ ] friends yeah
you know I'm saying this is it right
here it'll be yourself and he done in
the major leagues if you're in the minor
leagues and you having a hard time just
think of [ __ ] this [ __ ] Savage he
did it and stuck to it there's a
handsome guy if I look like it might be
having threesomes everything oh man one
eight ball every hour on the hour from
10:00 to 12:00 wrapping off in the
[ __ ] mail slot yeah I'm saying I beat
my own ass dog I don't want to be that
type of party
what else is dog anything else you want
to drive much man I just love you watch
Lou
I love University I got a scoop to look
at this [ __ ] beauty I'll get this
look at this Abbi Molly I think we got
playing the heads drugs and leaves just
bad guys coming to kind of [ __ ] buzz
aldrin out there brother
you made my day little every time I see
you you make my day
you know the gate how'd it get out right
here thank you for everything Lee thank
you so much man
anybody would be 2 million you got it
you're doing a good job you know I love
you [ __ ] hold on
yeah the accent in patina Rosie no no
good thing send them my love [ __ ]
thank you for coming by you know I love
you same here you're doing your [ __ ]
thing well look I appreciate the support
if you ever need anything for me come on
you know your [ __ ] family hate it
this is how we do it on the [ __ ]
church on a beautiful Monday that's how
you start off a [ __ ] Monday people
you people gonna wake up today you were
feeling who'd be dope and a long weekend
I took my kid listen it's [ __ ] hard
work we all know we signed up for
I'm working more hard I'm working harder
at 54 they wouldn't leave the dog for
good then when I was a [ __ ] burglary
I'm saying when I was a burglar life was
[ __ ] and easy now I gotta get up every
morning and really steel with three
[ __ ] hands so like I said before I
think a dr this poor bastard he used to
be out seven nights a week and
Hollywood game we're gonna be sober he
looks [ __ ] great he's always got a
story for you and that's the way we
[ __ ] do it in the church what's
happening now before you get out of here
let me read you something real quick let
me tell you about a little something and
then we'll get you the [ __ ] out of here
tip-top Who am I gonna I'm not gonna
hold you up there's a bunch of punk as
you always - who the [ __ ]
[ __ ] mine anyway like I told you
- beginning of the [ __ ] show right
there's not a lot of things I like and I
believe in Lee was on it I was on it you
know Lee really stuck to it for a long
time I mean he stood I think he just got
another shipment a blue another shipment
coming up my dad does it every week your
dad still lives on it you're single you
don't want to shop you're less than four
days a week you go on blue apron three
days a week it comes to your house right
to your door you pull it in you take it
out of the box and there comes all the
stuff you need to make the recipe they
give you a card when how to do it and
each meal it come on 40 minutes 15
minutes you take a shower and bam your
meal is settled you're ready to go
that's what blue aprons all about
because you choose from a variety of new
recipes each week or you let blue a
please culinary team surprise you
recipes are not repeated within a year
so you'll never ever ever get bored you
customize your recipes each week based
on your preferences so blue apron has
several delivery options so you can
choose what fits your needs and there's
no weekly commitment so you only get
deliveries when you want each meal
listen comes with a step-by-step
easy-to-follow recipe card proportionate
ingredients and can be prepared in 40
minutes or less Ginette 40 minutes or
less blue aprons freshness guarantee
promises that every ingredient in your
delivery arrives ready to cook or
they'll make it right check out this
month's menu
they got sweet pepper chicken with
bok choy and rice do you not I make bok
choy well you know this is your
opportunity to learn you ready for this
one
black bean and cheese tortoise Jesus
with roasted broccoli and lime sour
cream do you not to make that no you
don't how about this how about listener
shrimp and pesto fettuccine with spinach
this is a 30-minute meal and a customers
favorite seared chicken roasted four
vegetables with tape abut a pan sauce
there you sitting it for dinner blue
apron that's what you're gonna have for
dinner here's what I'm gonna do for you
with savages what are you thinking I
have an uncle Joey because I'm some some
Mook from the other side no cuz I'm
looking you up Savage okay check I told
you check out this week's menu what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna give 30 dollars
off your first meal and that coming home
to your house free shipping did I tell
you that already
free shipping you gonna blow a prince
calm slash Joey
check out the menu you're gonna love how
it good it tastes you'll love how good
it feels
and you're gonna love to create
incredible home-cooked meals with blue
apron so don't wait right now you know
you want to save money blue apron calm
slash Joey it's a better way to cook
blue apron calm you know you're gonna
tweet me and go Joey I'm living like a
doctor over here number two listen
Thanksgivings coming you've been single
for a long time you don't smell you got
a nice John you got a little bit of
credit you know you're your father
mm but cares you know your way from the
punch that take it any way you want to
look good you want to feel comfortable
that's your how come you gotta have me
on this me undies make feel good on
these your butt will be proud to wear
don't be the most comfortable pair under
way you'll ever own and to check it out
yourself gonna be on this comm slash
judges your Joey with tons of styles and
patterns from camouflages to the polka
dots you choose from both men and women
the undies will have the perfect fit for
you or your personality you follow me
the me undies feeling is unmatched
because they're naturally soft fabric
that is three times
often in cotton now for a limited time
only checkout me on these first ever
glow-in-the-dark print Joey what are you
talking about
glow-in-the-dark print Joey you must be
kidding me glow-in-the-dark print lights
out why not update your underwear drawer
and glow at the same time can you
imagine you mean a girl your dreams you
mean around that tendon stuff you come
out of the bathroom you got go on the
dark underwear it's dark with a candle
on who's talking about Halloween hear me
undies that ho and if underwear is that
your thing me and these always makes the
softest socks in the world listen like I
told your fears I've been using me on
these specially when I go to jujitsu
especially when I'm short time why cuz
it's Hana
and you want to have la mean Kia nice
and soft correctamundo
correctamundo so what happens is you
don't have no moisture down there you
know you don't smell like a billy goat
it draws away from everybody and
everybody's happy go to me on this give
them a try what I'm gonna do for you is
this I'm gonna get you 20% off the best
and softest underwear and Sasha ever
owned free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee from your uncle
Joey it's the holidays [ __ ] go to be
on these dot-com / Joey right now
that's me undies calm 20% off the best
and softest underwear and socks you'll
ever own free shipping and
hundred-percent satisfaction guarantee
go to me on these dot-com / Joey stay
black thank you very much to my main man
Theo von I want to do a spot at the
Comedy Store but thank you very much for
you savages will be back to Tuesday and
Wednesday I've made up my mind but if I
don't talk to you happy Halloween you
bad [ __ ] and I want to thank my
main man the main [ __ ] of life
my little brother Lisa at four always
showing up and dropping knowledge on his
uncle Joey and that's it and that's that
I want to thank blue apron one more time
I want to thank me on these I want to
thank you [ __ ] for listening
I'm gonna drop a little something on you
from Willie Cologne Hector Lavoe
off the album not cave whatever at crime
pays Blastoise [ __ ] Li I love
you [ __ ]
see you guys in Omaha Nebraska or the
following week it got them